the predator in theaters near you this
Friday check it out starring in part
this man keegan-michael key right here
on the show good to see his journey back
my friend yeah good to have you here
good to have you like we were hanging
out at the Super Bowl last year so much
fun and before we get to the movie in
sports I do have to just hit when with
you and and and peel the key and peele
the pieces you did
mocking SportsCenter with the teachers
the teachers yeah was brilliant and then
then the the names of the players
introducing themselves a football broad
yeah yeah yeah I mean that had to be
just were there ones that hit the floor
that you didn't use or no what happened
was I kind of Jordan was not a football
fan at the time okay he played Madden
but he wasn't an actual forbidden follow
the intrigue of every individual season
yes and I was explaining to him how they
used to do the they used to do the
introductions and so I told him about
Monday Night Football and I remember
watching him a night football game where
the Oakland Raiders were playing they
said it now little bit of Defense and
they're showing the faces come up and
the guys are all saying you know my name
is my name going to school my name is my
name I went to this school and then they
get to Charles Woodson and Charles
Woodson goes Charles Woodson safety you
know to school now of course I know this
girl and rich knows the school and joins
said no he didn't I said yes he did now
I'm now I'm exaggerating okay could have
been three days it could have been a
week but I'm just gonna say for the sake
of the story
the next day I come into the office and
Jordans like standing there he goes to
take a look at this tell me what you
think five pages of all of those names
what did you do last night and does it
start with an S and rhyme with ateva you
know I was like how did you come up with
these names and he did not a single name
hit the floor that was it that was it
he wrote the sketch over a night based
on Charles II son Charles Woodson saying
you know the school so they made up all
the schools I mean the guide the work
you understand
Jordan peels work ethic is out of this
world it's really a thing to behold and
so I just kind of
just offered him some information and
then he and he crafted that whole thing
by itself that's amazing
those those just sending up those sports
moments that we all take for granted
three pumps and it was really great gosh
okay so now it's really great football
Monday Night Football I'm trying to I
don't even know how to segue this here
you being a Detroit Lions Lions fan yeah
you did not see any of it though Carell
no fortunately enough for me yes yeah my
wife was furiously texting on the on the
phone with a friend while we were we
were in the air and eventually just said
what's what's happening and she goes and
she just shows me the phone 31:17 how
much time we can catch up Golden's in
there Golden's in there okay I like TJ
Jones like Marvin Johnston we could
still no no didn't happen
but here's my concern rich my concern is
as I think I mentioned to you earlier
we're worse I was already concerned that
it's gonna take a while to find this
everyone to fall into place and the
pieces to of this system that mr.
patricia is bringing to our fair city
yes and so I understand that I want
people to see I see him I'm in my mind
I'm going he's like the new buddy Ryan I
give this is what's gonna be real and
he's gonna this guy's gonna there's give
me these exotic packages and it's gonna
be great we're gonna confound offenses
with this defense to the tune of 48
points you know I just
oh my guess is my first seeing of it
okay now seeing these yeah just putting
the so we're literally just putting the
band-aid on and then ripping it off so I
and then and then I felt with us
pig-picking Frank rag now from Arkansas
to be the to be on our offensive line
we're trying to shore up an offensive
line this I don't know I don't even know
what happened how many yards did that
was me that's me that's like look at
that all the Lions fans the cards by the
way the cutaways of the Lions fans after
another after another of just still I
guess look in the misery
yeah this was supposed to be 100 percent
are the
one guaranteed win of the month I mean
so Mike I so I'm very concerned I'm very
very concerned keegan-michael here here
on the Rich Eisen show we we did discuss
yesterday about how troubling it is of a
track record of Belichick assistants yes
trying to improve upon whatever that
magic sauce is rare right in New England
and it's miss they leave in some once
they get out of the tractor beam yes you
know in real life we all know that you
leave the tractor beam and you go to the
Alderaan system or where it used to be
and then you can you can you can
actually build a really good rebellion
and destroy a almost fully operating
Death Star yes of course
but in but in this world that is not
real that I live in apparently that is
well once you get out of the tractor
beam of Darth Belichick you lose your
power for some reason you're no longer
powerful you're the lightsabers not
working right it's it's really it really
is a strange strange trend and I think
that what happens is part of it is look
money money talks right so if you're
sitting if you're being screamed at or
dressed down at Gillette it doesn't
matter because you can withstand that
knowing that there are just Super Bowl
rings on everybody's fingers around here
it is a winning culture you can't deny
it's a winning culture so you're gonna
stay you're gonna take it you're gonna
persevere if you come to a different
type of program this that may not may
not it certainly has proven to not be
the case well Mike Dell 2fo Rich Eisen
show audio exec yes Mike believes Asher
believes it's Bella checks fault
and also to prove that point tell him
about your your tree by Bill Walsh and
all of his great it's insane not just
Hill Walsh's tree but you wanna do this
guy's what about my audio tree I have
like 30 35 guys that have been working
since 94 all over LA they do Conan
Dancing with the Stars
it all started under me I have a good
pedigree of course see that's the way
you do it wrong Sam Weiss Mike Holmgren
yes you've got all these guys coming up
ever the sound engineer Superbowl is
you've been disseminating talent exactly
for over I'm gonna say two decades this
angle and the true stamp of a champion
and then Bell check his Schmo who sits
there and I gotta put it lightly all
those guys come out they're terrible
horrible he's still getting paid how
terrible of a job did he really do money
is not the sign of success sir that's
not that's not a metric I mean whoever
that lawyer is must have come out from
under a very good Michael Richardson
show and we we were talking about say
qualm Barkley in this league and how
special he is going to be does that make
you at all interested in the Giants well
my wife is a Giants fan
oh she was already she'd already staked
her claim as a kid she's from New York
she's a native New York right so she
already loved it and then you know she
you have no choice if you're in my life
I'm gonna make you love Penn State I'm
just gonna make you love Penn State and
the things that are happening right
there magic with with Franklin and so
last year when I did the blue-white game
when I was that we were the guest
coaches at the blue-white game my wife
by the way first female guest coach of
the white game spring scrimmage and say
quantum is there and so I walked up to
him I gave him a hug and the last time I
had seen him was at I think the last
time I saw him might have been right as
they were leaving the room to get
dressed for the 2016 a Big Ten
championship game and when they scored
those like whatever it was 31 on it and
on it sir points right against Wisconsin
and so he gives me how good she's just a
good kid gives me a hug can I go come
over and watch you meet my wife honey
honey ELISA take one take one take one
and she walks right up to say Kwan
shakes his hand she goes it's so nice to
meet you please come play for the Giants
no break no break at all and he goes you
know not up to me is that up to me but
but I think then getting what's the
kid's name what's the big kids named
Hernandez the Olin kid yes
and sake 1 they're making they're gonna
make their mark - I think he's a really
really special talent he is special
talent smart kid
good work ethic super gifted and I think
that he actually brings he brings a
winning culture to that team I mean so I
think if you got the rookie coming this
way and you have a two-time Super Bowl
champ like Eli coming this way right
we're gonna we're gonna find something
and I feel like I'm watching Odell
mature before our very eyes as well
that's the idea that's the idea that's
the plan it's hard we're both NFC fans
that's tough right right but you know I
can I can I can have two NFC teams so
what's it like let's let's talk about
the predator here with you sir
keegan-michael key here on the show we
you you already made obviously a Star
Wars reference you're you're from the
pop culture era of the US I guess right
what's it like for you to be in a movie
the predator this is this history of
this series this is one of those things
this is one of those sometimes you have
dreams deferred that you didn't even
know you had like I got to be on
Broadway last year I got to do a show on
Broadway what I let that dream go a long
time ago this wasn't even a dream I knew
I had what I could be in a predator
movie look at what I'm like six one
coming in at like 185 I have not said
Baker so it was it was it was really a
dream come true and and it was such a
lovely ensemble to work with the people
that I work with and and I was really
appreciative that our director Shane
Black he said okay I want there to be
humor in the film I'm gonna hire actors
who can do comedy it wasn't like it
nothing against comedians I enjoy the
comedian's very much sure what their
craft is but it's better than having
let's stunt cast it let's stunt cast it
let's not cast it and I think sometimes
people forget stunt cat like even going
we're gonna put Rob Gronkowski in the
movie that that's different that's
different than Jesse the body being in
the first one Jesse the body for all
intents and purposes is an actor he was
an actor at the day WUF the running man
with him and it was great
uh the running man to me isn't totally
over it's under way it's under under
yeah
with a lot of social commentary rest the
get out of it's time it's it's I think
that that situation is always you know
you can start cast for a certain effect
and I get it but you it's got to always
make sense and I was really appreciative
that I got to work with these this
particular group of actors there was a
lot of interesting and unique chemistry
that we had mmm all positive and and so
this experience has been one that's it's
also special to me because I'm taking a
turn in my career as I'm you know
surveying new opportunities I look and I
go okay I want to do more action I want
to hold guns more I want to do some
espionage stuff that's that's always
been something that's been really dear
and near to my heart hidden as a cinema
goer yeah yeah yeah and so yeah so I
this has been one of the first steps in
that direction okay so in that regard
let's let's play the predator version of
stark bench caught here on be quiet
okay all right let's do the the predator
ones here with uh Keegan Michael key
you wanna money you have the music right
here first art bench cut for for here on
the Rich Eisen show from the original
cast of predator who would you take in a
cage match fight in his prime Arnold
Jesse Ventura are Carl Weathers would I
would I fight them no who would you take
in a cage okay so Arnold you have to
start one bench one and cut one Arnold
Jesse venture or Carl Weathers
okay I'm I'm cut I'm cutting I'm cutting
Arnold hear me out cutting Arnold
sculpting making a physique look
symmetrical does not mean you have
endurance okay I'm benching Jesse the
body let's be honest who's never really
had that much of a body
I don't okay I mean the body was really
more his you know his aura yeah can't
take the shots can't take the shots I'm
starting Carl Weathers the guy had to
box the endurance is there no I don't
know a Carl Weathers ground-and-pound is
looking like right but I'm starting him
I'm sure I'm starting the guy who I
believe has the most endurance okay now
that here's the next one
here's the next one like that talk that
out from the original Kyle of that with
great talking from the original cast of
predator who would you take in a cage
match fight right now at his current age
Arnold at 71 Jesse Ventura at 67 or Carl
Weathers at 70 okay I'm okay this one
cutting your cutting Jesse out he's out
now the other two gentlemen since I've
had I've been able do a little bit of
research do some scouting okay
shook Carl Weathers hand at the Vanity
Fair Oscar party last year that's that's
a hardy grip okay alright so he's he's
starting Arnold's benched so it's not
that much further apart than when
they're prime not it not it not not that
it's one flip by the way I just like the
way that you're not handling this all
willy nilly I give good talk out this is
by the way this is a method start bench
country alright we've never done this
Mike are you ready to do this you told
them about no you told him about how you
you are the Bill Walsh of audio exactly
you can't screw these up okay yes okay
there we go one at a time your favorite
catchphrase from the original predator
go ahead here's one please we can kill
it alright that's number one
here's number two okay
[Music]
so what I'm gonna do I'm doing this
blindfolded Bill Walsh cannot have the
volume up the bill also sound engineers
not have the volume up for the second
you want to try it one more time now we
can kill it okay okay here's the next
one
[Music]
and here's the other one okay start
bench cut all right
get to the chopper gets cut because it's
only an incidental line and the only
reason we remember it is because he's
Austrian any other actor on the history
of the planet and by the history of the
planet I mean the states because it's
1987 right - the only a country that
exists is the United States of America
if anybody else said did you the
choppers it wouldn't have been a line it
wouldn't have been a line it's only
because he's the our shop booth because
he's Austrian cut cut it's superfluous
Wow
we're gonna bench we're gonna bench you
because I have to be a commie I have to
be a comedian of integrity who works
from the highest point of intelligence
we only like that because we were all 16
any swarm so what you're gonna do is
you're gonna start if it bleeds we can
kill it because it hey because it's a
succinct line it furthers the plot and
it's done in a very naturalistic way
please you can kill it very well for
everybody else who comes in here on the
Rich Eisen show we're gonna show up in
the bar we're gonna show them this stark
bench cut because you have raised the
bar key right here we're gonna just to
make you feel better Matt just sit what
I did yesterday I was on an interview
yesterday talking to Dan Levitt argh
sure huge huge predator fan who is my
favorite character bill bill bill Duke
like every character right you are and I
said I said Bill Duke may he rest in
peace his engineer goes I don't I think
I think Bill Duke still with us and then
I went oh no I met bill Nunn bill Nunn
who played radio raheem under I just had
TJ you can vouch for this I just had my
black card revoked for three months
because I'm a black person who mixed up
black people it's one month Oh Thank You
TJ all right TJ Jefferson yes thank you
okay
reinstated in one month okay thank you
so much one time I was on SportsCenter
so matter hope that makes you feel a
little better one time I was doing a
SportsCenter with Stuart Scott and he
referred to the late great Richard Pryor
and he was not dead yet and it was
during a commercial break where Aaron's
like Stu there's Richard Pryor is he's
alive not well but alive it's one of
those things too you have to fix
mistakes because that was the days when
things were really there at 2:30 in the
morning like we're fixing the fact that
he killed off I killed off Bill Duke I
by the way can I just ask this question
sure we've been saying this about Abe
Vigoda since 1990 is he still alive
Rickles oh he's gone you just recently
just recently no okay okay here's my
backtrack I said that because I wanted
to make you more of a legend than you
already are in my mind well done man
but he did not spoiler alert I don't
think he made it in the film check out
the predator in theaters this Friday I
can't wait for everybody to see and have
a great time at it you're the man
thanks for coming Michael key follow
Mike Egan M key on Twitter the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience